[Applause]
welcome back everybody we are still here
with lisa welch from rachel bloom give
it up
and we're having an 80s celebration
y'all um while i'm about celebrating my
upcoming 40th birthday i'm very excited
i also wanted to use this week-long
party to shine a light on causes that
are close to my heart anyone who knows
me at all knows that i'm a huge animal
lover i always say that animals can
often be better than humans because it's
a true statement
do you agree
anna my dogs are amazing
um there's a sanctuary just outside la
that not only rescues animals in need
they also invite humans to come by and
bond and they heal with the animals it's
really really cool from kindred spirits
care farm let's say hi to maria
pierre the goat and amaya chicken
yes
[Applause]
[Music]
oh my gosh
oh my gosh
wait what is she does she have a diaper
on i'm wearing a diaper
hello
oh my gosh you are are we allowed to pet
we're allowed to like you want to give
him a carrot can i put this here is that
okay fine can i give a carrot can i grab
her would you hold this yes got it
okay you're gonna babysit are we gonna
be friends
are we gonna be friends you think if you
give me a carrot we'll be best friends
oh my gosh how healing i just gave him
one i didn't know how many you wanted to
give um well hello and welcome to the
show meet rachel me lisa nice to meet
you shall i gather more i feel like our
names
rachel lisa kelly these are like all
names from 80s movies as well and marina
is like amazing i just thought of that
um well tell us about your animals here
so this is pierre right this is hanson
pierre and pierre was rescued about two
years ago with his girlfriend perla um
and then we have amaya and she was
recently rescued off of a slaughterhouse
truck and she came to us very sick
and she had pneumonia and our director
karen nursed her back to health we
wasn't we weren't sure if she was gonna
make it but now she loves sitting on lap
she's like a lap chicken
and uh they're living their best lives
at the care farm come up here so you're
so cute you're so cute i'm not trying to
say something amazing eyes you like
karen
oh my god i just love how you eat it so
tell us more about the farm
uh well our director karen started this
care farm in 2013 and she wanted a
special place that didn't just rescue
animals but helped rescue people who had
trauma or needed healing in some way and
so we have this beautiful space with
alpacas emus um oh you want to come down
okay she's like this is my moment let me
shine ma'am let me shine all right have
your momentum
um horses a donkey sheep
goats pigs tortoises we have a great
pyrenees named hava a dog yes this is
all our our sweet babies oh you're in
the middle
so happy all the time i know it's pretty
amazing to go there and volunteer and we
also have a community garden so if
you're not into animals and you still
want to be outside and let nature heal
you yeah he moves they're hilarious and
yeah my god that's beautiful and so
we're working oh i got you opening the
garden and if he's too much i can take
oh no no no i haven't even met henry my
dog
he's in my lap usually he's huge he
thinks he's small um hi hey i'm hungry
too i get it i'm like waiting for lunch
over here so she's just hanging out
so visitors get into the farm and
from the farm they get a unique
experience right so
tons of experiences one can have we uh
you can come and volunteer you can come
and visit just the regular public we're
open on sundays from 10 to two but we
also offer during the week um
high school kids or elementary school
kids to come and learn about the animals
learn about horticulture learn about
composting that's so cool
i would love to have learned that when i
was a kid i mean i would now i'm like
13. me too it's amazing and we also then
have programs for adults to come that
need healing like veterans um people
living in so sober living homes that can
come and usually adults want to get
their hands dirty so maybe they want to
scoop poop we got tons of that they want
to help build um a pen for the animals
or fix it up or work in the gardens um
have a purpose that's selfless that's
nice exactly and just being outside one
more
cherish
cherish
oh i don't care i'm like literally i
love animals more than humans um so how
do you see the farm growing in the
future oh we have seven acres and we'd
love to expand we have beautiful rocks
and boulders on the property so we'd
love to be able to fence them in so yeah
so goats can run and jump because goats
and rocks is like bliss right yeah we
want to grow out our community garden
and karen our director her ultimate goal
is to have a wallopini which is a a
semi-subterranean greenhouse and use it
as a workshop place and to teach about
horticulture and gardening and this is
the coolest spot ever you have to come
yeah yes
it's really close to about 25 minutes
from here yeah and it's amazing that you
can go to such a peaceful place that's
in within the bounds of los angeles yeah
relax and heal and be amongst in such a
busy city yeah because this is like for
me i grew up like out in the country so
it's like it's very different for me i
like i feel like emotionally it's hard
in a city like that it's packed and
you're not used to it it's such a
healing thing to have you need a reset
every now and then and just lower your
vibration and yeah animals do that
they're pretty you lower my vibration
you're very cool you are so cool
um we are obsessed with everything the
kindred spirits care farm does so we are
giving the sanctuary five thousand
dollars
just buy all the carrots all the carrots
for pure
[Music]